Es posible que ya estén familiarizados con la
ley de Coulomb, que es la ley más importante
o subyacente detrás de todo lo que sabemos sobre
la electrostática y cómo las cosas con cargas se
atraen o rechazan entre sí. Pero una versión
simplificada de la ley de Coulomb es que la
magnitud de la fuerza entre partículas cargadas
va a ser proporcional al producto de las cargas,
por lo que q₁ sería la carga de una de las
partículas cargadas, tal vez es un ion,
y q₂ sería la carga de la otra partícula, tal vez
sea ion, dividido entre r². Y si estamos hablando
de iones, r será la distancia entre sus núcleos:
si las cargas son diferentes, será una fuerza de
atracción, y si las cargas son las mismas, será
una fuerza de repulsión. Y podemos usar la ley
de Coulomb para pensar en compuestos iónicos, así
que vamos con el que quizá sea el compuesto iónico
más común en nuestra vida diaria: la sal de mesa.
La sal de mesa es cloruro de sodio. Hemos hablado
de esto en otros videos. El cloruro de sodio está
compuesto de cationes sodio con carga positiva,
por lo que tenemos un Na⁺. El sodio es un elemento
del grupo 1, por lo que le es muy fácil perder un
electrón y luego tener una carga positiva,
y está formado también por un anión cloruro,
Cl¯. El cloruro es un elemento del grupo 7 que
realmente quiere ese electrón extra, para tener
8 electrones de valencia en su nivel más externo,
por lo que es muy probable que atrape un electrón,
tal vez de un sodio. Entonces, estos dos
elementos se atraerán entre sí. Noten que
tienen cargas opuestas. Y cuando tenemos un
montón de sodio y cloruro juntos, tendremos
una estructura que se parece a esto. Y en Química
llamamos a esto retícula. Ahora, en el lenguaje
cotidiano podemos asociar una retícula con un
tipo de patrón de líneas cruzadas como este,
pero en Química, cuando hablamos de una retícula,
estamos hablando de una estructura tridimensional
de átomos o una estructura tridimensional de iones
que tienen un patrón repetitivo, y podemos verlo
aquí. En futuros videos veremos con más detalle
las estructuras reticulares. Pero podemos ver
en esta imagen que los púrpuras son los de sodio y
los verdes son los iones cloruro, y podemos ver en
la tabla periódica de los elementos la razón por
la cual los cationes sodio son tan pequeños. Hemos
dicho que a medida que avanzamos hacia la derecha
el radio disminuye, pero lo que sucede es que
cuando el sodio pierde ese electrón más externo
sus electrones quedan con una configuración de gas
noble de neón, entonces pierde esa tercera capa,
se hace más pequeño y no sólo pierde esa tercera
capa, sino que tiene 11 protones, por lo que
tendrá una fuerte atracción sobre los electrones
en esa segunda capa. Y, de manera similar, el
cloruro ganará un electrón, por lo que tendrá
una configuración de gas noble de argón, entonces
va a ser más grande. Ahora, cuando hablamos de
enlaces covalentes, hablamos de la energía de
enlace, la energía necesaria para separar los
átomos que formaban los enlaces covalentes. Existe
una noción similar para los enlaces iónicos como
este y es la energía reticular, y ésta es la
energía necesaria para separar los iones de
manera que queden infinitamente alejados unos
de otros. Y la energía reticular generalmente
se mide en Kilo-Jules por mol, que es también
en lo que medimos la energía de enlace, porque
en realidad son la misma noción, excepto que la
energía reticular rompe una retícula de iones,
mientras que con energía de enlace normalmente
nos referimos a enlaces covalentes. Ahora,
quiero que piensen en algo: ¿qué va a tener una
energía reticular más alta, será el cloruro de
sodio? O escojamos algo más: cloruro de rubidio.
¿Cuál tendrá una energía reticular más alta?,
¿cuál va a necesitar más energía para separar
los iones? Y les daré una pista con esta tabla
periódica de los elementos. Muy bien. El cloruro
de rubidio, que en lugar de un catión sodio está
compuesto por un catión rubidio, entonces tenemos
Rb⁺ y, por supuesto, tenemos el anión cloruro,
Cl¯. ¿Y cuál es la diferencia aquí?
El anión es cloruro en ambos casos,
pero cuando comparamos el rubidio con el sodio,
el rubidio tendrá una estructura electrónica de
kriptón cuando pierda un electrón; mientras
que el sodio, una vez que pierde un electrón,
su configuración electrónica se verá como el neón,
por lo que el catión sodio es más pequeño. ¿Y qué
nos dice esto? Bueno, si este está aquí, voy a
rodearlo así, si esto es más pequeño y tenemos
cargas similares en la parte superior, tenemos
1 positivo y 1 negativo en la parte superior,
que son las cargas entre los dos iones. Pero ahora
tenemos un radio más pequeño entre los núcleos,
porque el sodio es más pequeño que el rubidio,
mientras el radio disminuye, la fuerza aumenta,
por lo que tendremos fuerzas de Coulomb más
fuertes en una retícula de cloruro de sodio que
en una retícula de cloruro de rubidio. Debido a
que la fuerza de atracción es fuerte se necesitará
más energía para separarlo, por eso vamos a tener
una energía reticular más alta para el cloruro de
sodio que para el cloruro de rubidio. Pensemos
en otro compuesto iónico. Digamos que tenemos
fluoruro de magnesio y éste está compuesto de un
catión magnesio que tiene una carga positiva de 2,
entonces 2 más, en una retícula con un montón de
aniones fluoruro. Entonces, ¿cómo se compararía la
energía reticular del fluoruro de magnesio con
lo que acabamos de ver aquí? El magnesio tiene
una carga mayor que estos cationes aquí arriba,
por lo que, si vemos la carga de magnesio como
q₁ no tendrá algo más grande allá arriba y ese
fluoruro es un anión más pequeño que el cloruro.
Podemos ver eso si miramos la tabla periódica de
los elementos nuevamente: el flúor es más pequeño
que el cloro, por lo que incluso si agregamos un
electrón a ambos, el fluoruro seguirá siendo más
pequeño, y el magnesio, cuando le quitamos dos
electrones, tendrá la configuración electrónica
de gas noble neón, pero va a atraer aún más a
esos electrones de la segunda capa porque tiene
12 protones en comparación con el sodio que sólo
tiene 11. Entonces, lo que vemos aquí es que el
magnesio no sólo tiene una carga positiva mayor
que el catión sodio, sino que será más pequeño, y
el fluoruro tiene una carga comparable al cloruro,
pero también será más pequeño. Por lo tanto,
tenemos una carga mayor en la parte superior,
al menos para el magnesio, y tenemos radios más
pequeños en la parte inferior, por lo que en el
fluoruro de magnesio las fuerzas de Coulomb entre
los iones y la retícula son aún más fuertes, por
lo que la energía reticular, la energía necesaria
para separarla, será mayor, por lo que de los tres
que acabamos de ver la energía reticular más alta
será del fluoruro de magnesio, seguido por el
cloruro de sodio y luego el cloruro de rubidio.